Speaker 1: Hey, I want to play a video for
you that is really, really good because it
brings out a conversation that is a necessary
conversation to have. You know how Republicans
love to say we have our violent blue states and
violent blue cities and it's so dangerous to be
in what they call Democrat cities. Of course,
it's not true. And yesterday or this might be
actually from the day before. Is this yesterday,
I guess? Yeah, this is from yesterday. There was
a debate yesterday where in sitting Oklahoma,
Governor Kevin's pit is being challenged by
Democratic challenger Joy Hofmeister. And Stitt
tries the typical stuff. Democrats are bad for
crime and Democratic states are dangerous, and
they love to scapegoat New York and New York
City. And to her credit, Joy Hofmeister points
out, hey, you know what, Kevin? Violent crime is
higher in Oklahoma than it is in New York, and
she's completely correct. I'm going to give you
the data. This is not a matter of opinion.
He simply says, no, that can't possibly be
true. And there's something that the audience does
that's very revealing about how these Republicans
think and behave. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: So let's talk about the facts.
The fact is the rates of violent crime
are higher in Oklahoma on your watch
than in New York and California. That's a fact.
Speaker 3: Well, we'll have that fact checked
by the Frontier superintendent.
Speaker 2: It's also a fact.
Speaker 3: That they're going, do you
believe we have higher crime than New York
or California? That's why she just said.
Speaker 2: Safety and security is my.
Speaker 1: So Kevin's tit says that doesn't sound
right. You people don't believe that. Right. And
the crowd goes, no, no, no. This is the way they
operate. It just doesn't sound like the very stuff
we've been repeating. So it can't possibly be
true. Right. But it is very much true. These red
state folks have no idea that they are being lied
to and that blue cities and blue states are being
scapegoated for no reason. That has any connection
to reality. They don't have any idea how violent
their states are. If it doesn't sound right, it
must not be wrong. And of course, the reason it
doesn't sound right is because they're constantly
lied to about it. But it is true if you look at
the rate, the rate is crimes per population.
Of course, a state with a dramatically higher
population is likely to have more a higher number
of violent crimes because there's millions more
people in a lot of these high population states.
But what we care about is the rates, we care
about the rate. It's sort of like if I say more
people died of COVID in Florida than in Wyoming.
That doesn't really tell us much because
Florida's population is so much larger. Similarly,
if I say there are more crimes in New York City
than in Savannah, it doesn't really tell us much
because New York City has so many more people if
you look at the rates. Oklahoma was most recently
ranked 15th highest in the country for rate
of violent crime, and New York State was 26th.
It is without question that Oklahoma has a higher
rate of violent crime than New York State. And in
fact, this isn't really rare. If you look, this
is public data. I don't claim to have any kind of
monopoly on the data. If you look up top states
by violent crime rate of the top ten states,
you've got seven very red states, one purple
state, Nevada. And then you've got Washington,
D.C. and then there's like one more purple
state to purple. It's seven red states,
two purple states and Washington, D.C., which
isn't a state, but it's a territory. It's red
states. It's red states with the highest violent
crime rates. Now, you could say, well, David, sir,
you're being deceptive. Forget about Oklahoma and
New York State. What about Oklahoma City and New
York City? Fine. Do make the same comparison in
2022. So far, the Oklahoma violent crime rate is
40. And New York City is 28. That's this is a 1
to 100 where a higher number means more violent
crime. New York City's violent crime rate is
significantly lower than the violent crime rate in
Oklahoma City. And by the way, the property crime
rate is also dramatically lower in New York City,
25 versus 60 in Oklahoma City. They don't care
about the facts. Democrats run New York City. It
must be more violent. Well, okay. Not true.
Now, I can't get off of this topic without
mentioning one other important thing. This entire
conversation is also skewed because in general,
cities have more violence because of more
population density. Cities tend to be more
democratic, and often in blue states. But red
states also have cities, and they're often
significantly more violent. And the safest big
cities are all in very, very blue states. But
there is this base rate bias where Democrats tend
to prefer to live in cities versus conservatives.
And that's a systemic reality. Even still, the
numbers are not what these Republicans claimed
them to be. So Kevin Stitt laughing it off.
Absolutely true. What Joy Hofmeister said there,